[Music]
today with this morning's symposium in
the ceremonies this afternoon we
celebrate the life and honor the memory
of dr. Ronald E McNair Ron McNair earned
his PhD in physics here and we at MIT
are very proud of him
Ron's life which is tragically cut short
was marked by heroic accomplishment
courage and dedicated service to his
country his record stands as a model for
all young people to emulate and has
brought great honor to his family his
friends to this institution and indeed
to the whole country as most of you know
at MIT we have a center for Space
Research which shares a building with
the Department of aeronautics and
Astronautics and in the MIT tradition
this building has been known as building
37 for the past several years during the
past year there's been a groundswell of
opinion that this building should be
named for Ron McNair before this day is
finished building 37 will officially
become the Ronald E McNair building I
extend a warm welcome to all of you this
for this morning's symposium and I'm
especially pleased to welcome Ron's
family and his many close friends who
are here with us this morning all of you
of course are invited to attend the
dedication ceremonies this afternoon and
the reception which follows and now it
is my pleasure to introduce my colleague
professor Gordon Pettingill the director
of the Center for space research who's a
chairman this morning's symposium Gordon
thank you Jim
this morning in a program to commemorate
dr. Ronald McNair interest in advancing
science as well as his deep interest in
understanding how science affects man's
outlook we will hear from four speakers
all addressing a theme that was close to
Ron's heart the space frontier
unfortunately I was not able to know Ron
directly but from reading things that he
has written talking to people who knew
him his personal philosophy has come
through very clearly indeed this
philosophy is on the one hand to think
clearly to exercise one's intellect and
to do careful planning all of that's
essential but at the same time to push
hard against the frontiers of knowledge
to take chances where they are necessary
and in fact to hang it over the edge
this last phrase which is included in
the symposiums title was a favorite of
Ron's I gather that it originated in the
surfing and mountaineering communities
perhaps otherwise as well I don't know
where it epitomizes the daring that's
necessary to make one's mark even if it
leads to danger in Ron's case it
translates as a need never to let well
enough alone never to sit back fat and
happy as it were and always to perceive
and accept a new challenge I'm sure that
this theme which is so characteristic of
Ron will surface again and again in the
ceremonies today as Dean Brown has just
said Ron had a very strong involvement
with MIT coming here first on an
experimental program for talented
undergraduates and then later returning
to earn a doctorate in physics based on
research in the application of lasers to
spectroscopy
his was an educational success story in
every way we'll hear more of Ron's
personal life and recollections of
people who knew him well in this
afternoon's ceremonies but in this
morning we're going to highlight those
interests of Ron's which involve more
the scientific and the involvement of
man with science we will hear a series
of talks revealing how an inner drive
fed by the excitement of research at the
frontier has propelled scientists to
reach out for an understanding of the
heavens we hope that some of this
excitement and Wonder will be felt by
all of you our first speaker this
morning is Institute professor Philip
Morrison well known for his wide-ranging
interests in all the works of man
including extra rest
extraterrestrials too if we can only
find some he suffuses the discussion of
any topic with a tangible enthusiasm
that I'm sure most of you already know
he's backed by a distinguished career
that covers more than 20 that that
covers many many years 20 of them at MIT
and from this perspective phil has a
solid base on which to seek new insights
and ways of describing things which
we'll be hearing more of I'm sure it's a
compliment for me to say that I never
quite know where his talks are going to
lead and the one this morning is no
exception
Phil what do the heavens declare
[Applause]
Gordon I'm sure many people know what
the heavens declare it's of course a
literary allusion to one of the
strongest framework parts of the
framework of our speech the famous
translation of the Bible which goes the
17th century by that wonderful probably
the best of all committees appointed by
King James and in Psalm 19 of David
recommended of the chief musician as
everyone knows the text the 17th century
translating the poetry now three
thousand years old
tells us the heavens declare the glory
of God and the firmament showeth his
handiwork day unto day uttereth speech
and night unto night showeth knowledge
this for me is one of the most eloquent
statements of what I think must be the
chief source of the scientific temper in
in our species which goes back far
before even the poets of Jerusalem 3,000
years ago deep deep into the
archaeological past which were only
beginning now to grasp and understand it
seems quite plain and this quotation has
it almost explicit that the order of the
world the sense that there is some kind
of order pattern that we can perceive
has at least as one important source of
course the motion of the game the beat
of the heart all those things have their
role but the succession of day and night
the succession of the seasons which
which we are all from the beginning so
characterized and so marked must have
been one of the great stimuli to the
under look for order in other parts of
the world of our experience and I think
that's almost unquestionable and I that
as the oldest so in some sense the
astronomical rhythms which are not after
all
evident self-evident many jokes in all
cultures explain how the Sun is not so
important as the moon because the Sun is
out by day when you don't really need it
to move and this sense of causal
relationship between day and night the
position of the heavenly luminaries
that's the sort that you don't teach in
the schools but there's no question
that's a fundamental kind of
understanding of it abstraction which
everybody knows because that comes to
the child in the curious way and we have
that idea so I think this is quite
important by the time you have gotten
too rich your body of scientific
material proto scientific materials say
with the philosophers of Greece witches
which are so who are so well documented
it's probably only reason they stand out
for us they are well documented we have
their writings and we know very well
that they saw a commanding order in the
heavens and it was so grand for
Aristotle that he and his followers
divided the universe our experience into
two Dulli and said here below motion is
haphazard and faltering and turbulent
chaotic but above it is circular the
most perfect of forms here below matter
is earthy and dull and multiple and
impermanent but there it is shining and
here below things are born and die
things where away and degrade and change
and go but up there is perpetual 'ti so
they said the heavens are characterized
by suck they are circular shining and
perpetual and here on earth our
experience leads to the other sort of
phenomenon and that is not a bad
division of the world it was the
beginning of a theoretical understanding
I believe and I will say that most of
what we now know makes it deeply wrong
and we'll see how clearly that is
but it's wrong only in the sense that
all initial approximations are wrong it
transcended by a higher understanding
but right in its essence yes the heavens
are different but no it is not that we
are that different because we too are in
the heavens circling around on a planet
like the other planets just as shining
and circular perpetual as they are and
it was a 17th century the enormous rise
of science in the 17th century that gave
the strongest enrichment of this idea
which was not the novel idea of the 17th
century but which blossomed then on the
one hand the earth was a planet and
therefore shared these qualities and on
the other hand the planets were not that
distinct and different in another
creation from the earth but no part of
the same the moon was a place said
Galileo and the crater he could see he
compared to a plane in Bohemia and
circle flat and encircled by high
mountains and how could he say that for
the very best reason he could lay eyes
on it and he carefully watched the
sunrise on the mountain landscape of the
moon in the winter between 16:9 and 1610
from Florence and Padua for the first
time in the world people could see
enough detail to recognize that sunrise
and sunset on the moon were parallels to
sunrise and sunset in the mountains of
Italy or Czechoslovakia and of course
now the astronauts see the sunrise and
sunset as they circle the world but it's
the same sunrise and sunset in a way
which I think everyone would clearly
understand just not identically the same
but it has the same basis the same
origins in the same geometrical and
temporal description II saw so that
Venus was not the shining point that
would have to be required if all planets
were just like that Venus showed phases
like the moon to his telescope and he
knew the moon of course displayed phases
as the ancients had known as we always
have known and so for Aristotle the moon
had to be a boundary place it shared
something shining circulating for petrol
alley but not all it shared something of
the earth it was in between beyond the
moon were the heavens below the moon was
the earth the moon was on the frontier
and so of course we have made it in our
time the moon is still the only place
reached by human beings beyond this
earth the next unification was of course
the remarkable came very suddenly at the
end of the same century the remarkable
rise under Newton with a great deal of
help from Hooke and Huygens and the
others who produced the idea of
gravitation universal force of
attraction between all bodies of matter
not only sun and earth not only Jupiter
and his moons but of course earth and
Apple as everyone knows from the old
perhaps true story of the fall of the
Apple but I find it quite striking
though interested always in this
extension of these notions I find it
quite striking to recall that it took
about generation generation and a half
before the Royal astronomer Sir Nevil
Maskelyne verified what Newton in his
book of course had to recognize what all
the physicists then admitted knew that
the bodies that draw each other here on
earth like the book and the not the
earth but the book in my hand have a
tiny force between them if Newton is to
be right why is this force insensible
why don't we notice it why is attraction
restricted to the heavens or to the
earth the great ball of the earth
against everyday things only because of
quantity only because the force is so
small and it was masculine who first had
the brilliant idea and carried it
through actually others has proposed
that if you made very careful surveys on
either side of a mountain he chose him
out in the Highlands of Scotland and
moved one side the mountain the other
and used your telescope very carefully
and your plumb-bob very carefully you
could measure the fact that the plumb
bar would incline ever so slightly
towards the mountain a mountain being
about the smallest object that would
even a force to be detected by the
implementation of that day and it worked
and it worked and he could measure the
density of the mountain compared to the
dense of the earth and so on and from
then on we have not gone without the
direct knowledge now an everyday
experiment not still an easy one in the
laboratory to show that LED balls do in
fact attract something else in the
laboratory of course it does not be led
but this sense of universal gravitation
and the laws of motion that went with it
unified the motion fully for hundreds of
years of the development of the heart of
mathematically mathematically aimed
science that's to say physics and the
other Natural Sciences from the time of
Newton from 1700 let me say until
approximately nineteen fifty or sixty
but without yet that final unification
which is to say yes we now recognize the
earth must be a planet there must be
shining circular and perpetual so to
speak and the planets share the same
earthiness that we have we are all one
universe is single I'm very moved by the
eloquent account that Galileo also made
it though he was not the first to Vinci
did the same to describe the evidence
for the shining quality of the earth not
of course by going into orbit as people
now have seen it but by looking for the
reflection of the earth light upon the
moon and his careful account of that his
analogies and comparisons and so on
innocent very much measurement but using
plenty of arguments derived from walking
through the streets of Florence and
watching the Sun Shine on different
surfaces he was able to show quite
conclusively that the so-called old moon
in the new moons armed phenomenon is a
phenomenon of earth shine from the
clouds to the east of your observation
point and this is of course now nicely
demonstrated we have no doubt and so
when first a satellite went into orbit a
little cranky thing of a hundred or two
hundred pounds with the errors the
designer and the fingerprints the
machine is still on and then fighting
with human beings men and women also
went into space the final unity was
established it was not just mathematical
it was not just in the laboratory but it
was realized in
every day way and that has had a great
impact I'm sure upon the imagination of
most people see what I am talking about
is not the specific things of astronomy
but the hold upon the our own minds the
way we see the world which all over the
world has been dominated by these
regularities and generalities that come
from the pursuit of our place in the
wider universe that which we call
astronomy and all assessments so I feel
that the unity of motion and force was
the sort of the second thing that we
have and its implications for everyday
life of course are manifold as an
engineering institution bears witness
Newton's mechanics are taught just about
in all departments the next remark I
want to make is the universality of
matter the unity of matter in the
universe again that was hard-won
information but it was signs were there
IRA just reached our beautiful analysis
and photograph of a dagger owned by the
mogul Emperor Jahangir about 1600 in
which is folded in the middle of this
wonderful dagger beautifully inscribed
is folded a small piece of meteoric iron
for a meteor that fell on the pudding
job and was rushed to the Emperor they
said it was something that came in a
bolt of lightning but it was obviously
marvelous and iron and stars have a name
very much reassembling each other in
many languages and probably the sign of
this heavenly sent iron has had a big
effect in the imagination of people so
there was some feeling that matter was
not just here and the mountains gave the
form of the matter on the moon when you
see mountains you know they're rock
though you don't really know that
they're rock they might be something
that resembles rock and indeed the
scholastic critics of Galileo made much
of this possibility and talked about
glassy coverings and many other English
gent bother but the simplicity of the
story really made its way known and as I
think all people have studied some
physics know from these ideas of
meteorites and pieces of iron the
spectroscope which itself derived from
the rainbow and for the color sense of
human beings who can distinguish colors
so well
with the inborn gift of eye color which
most people have not all was
demonstrable as a means of analyzing
light itself without getting any sample
from light itself you can penetrate the
matter which is the makeup the
composition of the source of the light a
truly remarkable effect so that an
exposure a few photographs or even
looking with the eye and the
spectroscope is the same as getting a
teaspoonful
from a distant star and taken to the
chemist in fact on the whole rather
better probably takes much much more
than a teaspoonful and we learned then
that the not only is it formed the same
way not only as matter earthy and so on
everywhere with the of course the
exceptions the Sun is not as
incandescent and we understand that now
but matter too and earth can become
incandescent fleetingly and so the Sun
is incandescent fleetingly but
fleetingly for the sun is a good matter
of ten billion years so we have to
understand these adjustments to the
inborn human scale and human abilities
but it is the same stuff the same
chemical elements and from the word you
recognize the word helium comes of
course from the Greek Helios for the Sun
and helium was an element discovered
first by a spectrum in the Sun and not
known on earth but unmistakable even in
the poor state of atomic knowledge of
eighteen seventy or eighty when it was
discovered the Keen astronomers of those
day said yes this is another atom we
don't have this on earth and it was
found in 25 or 30 years later in
terrestrial samples and of course now
it's a commonplace of the of the stores
and the birthday party but it is really
quite wonderful it's lost to earth
mostly we have it in very rare amounts
because of its unique chemistry it has
no chemistry and therefore the earth
lost it in early days the Sun is still
10% five or ten percent helium the great
planets are largely helium helium is a
very common constituent of the universe
and we find in fact that the University
or everything we see is hydrogen and
helium in fact you say the universe that
we can see in all bands from the lowest
frequency radio to the gamma rays
we can see is pretty much made and has
the marks of hydrogen technical grade
hydrogen little helium yes and a certain
amount of 2% impurity to allow for
oxygen and iron and all the rest then
you have a pretty good description of
what the universe is made of you could
buy it you know in some chemical
warehouse a technical grade hydrogen
they would sell you this mixture and
from that all is made all that we see
and of course a wonderful sense of unity
and in addition and in addition a sense
of simplicity of youth of the pristine
because if you ask what characterizes
hydrogen and then what characterizes
helium is a lesser secondary element you
find they are the simplest the lightest
the least complex of all the stable
atoms we know and therefore they suggest
the processes are developing from
simplicity to complexity and this is a
sign they have not yet gone very far and
it's a very important sign and was a
cornerstone of contemporary effort to
understand the origins and fate of
matter and of ourselves with matter and
is not of course without its criticism
today and that's I want to close with
that because of course we're looking
forward always we're not just looking
backward that is one of the great
virtues of the scientific temperament
not always to its benefit but it is of
it is a part of its temperament we look
forward we look to the edge to see what
what we find and I simply want to close
by saying there are two discoveries of
the past 20 years one perhaps the past
five or ten years and one of 20 years
ago now quite elaborated so that they're
almost perhaps not entirely almost
beyond doubt the first is that by
looking at radiations which we never
expected to see radiations in the
microwave domain the millimetre domain
very hard for us to measure it became
plain that the radiation that came from
the dark parts of space between the
stars and between the galaxies was much
greater an amount only hard for us to
see not made for our eyes then all the
radiation came from stars and we
examined this with detail we found the
remarkable
still unbelievable property to me but
unquestionable its uniformity is beyond
comparison we know of no natural
phenomenon in the heaven a celestial
scale so uniform as the so called
background thermal background radiation
it is accurately the same in all
directions day and night summer and
winter north and south a name any way
you want to call Direction comes from
behind all the stars and galaxies and
must go back to a time when the universe
was still simple when still still
uniform when it had not made the complex
lumpy structures that we call galaxies
stars planets meteorites people and this
sense again of turning from the simple
to the complex is part of the story
which at least adds to the strength of
the intuition we got from the pristine
nature of hydrogen and helium and then
as I indicated not all as well not all
is so clearly understandable and a huge
success we are thrown into a tremendous
doubt and uncertainty by a wonderful
discovery which is now hard to down hard
do on the superficial level we can
understand it but the fact seems to be
true all that visible matter that glows
to us in all these wonderful spectral
bands some which could be seen from the
earth itself some which have to go into
space to see all of those seem to bring
us news we now have gravitational
evidence the news that we get by an
electromagnetic radiation is news of
only maybe 5 or 10% of all the mass that
is out there if we interpret the data in
the most likely and simplest way most of
the galaxies are mostly made of dark
matter so far invisible to all our
instruments and detectable only by their
now absolutely certain effect on the
orbiting of the bright objects that we
see orbiting around galaxies which our
little sample stars and nebulae that
perform their orbits and from those
orbits the physicists the astronomers
can make out what mass is causing them
to gravitate and that mass is simply too
large to be accounted for by
adding up all the stars and all the dust
and all the gas and all that we see by a
good factor not just by a little bit
which would certainly expect because
there must be something we don't see no
matter how well you see there's always a
little more you can see if you had
better light so we expect a little bit
but the fact that was not a little bit
but probably a factor of 10 is now the
largest quandary the largest challenge I
think which is before us we will try
very hard to find out what that stuff is
it's of course just possible there's
something wrong with our explanations
our law of gravity is wrong our laws of
motion are wrong that might be true many
people work in that direction I'm not
excluding that possibility but I think I
am saying what most people believe that
there looks as though for the first time
the wonderful guide that says as it is
here so it is to some degree above maybe
failing us we may be entering into a
domain where we see that what we see is
only a decoration upon a vast dark
region of gravitating matter probably
left over from an early in much simpler
condition but a condition that we whose
simplicity we do not yet understand
because our laboratory techniques and
our natural explorations have not yet
given us a sample of the kind of matter
we see there or maybe they make hints of
it in the highest energy laboratories we
don't know that's the kind of problem
which is fascinating to kind of play
that's the kind of problem solution many
members though perhaps not I of this
audience will see and what an exciting
time it will be and this is the domain
of astronomy to which the McNair
building and the hard work of many
engineering and scientific colleagues at
MIT and around the world in the past
decades have contributed not anew but as
the last step the latest not the last
the latest step in that chain of human
understanding intuition for which I
think a psalm 19 a psalm of David is a
very good introduction
thank you very very much film not really
in a situation to entertain questions
but if the were a really outstanding one
obviously our next speaker is university
professor Charles Townes of the
University of California at Berkeley
someone who is also very well known here
having served as mi t--'s Provost from
1961 to 1966
professor Townes is probably best known
as the father of the laser for which
development he shared the Nobel Prize in
1964 his participation here today is
highly appropriate not only for his
comments on astronomy and for man's role
in space but also as a representative of
South Carolina his home state where Ron
grew up I note also that as MIT Provost
in 1963
professor Townes played a very important
role in arranging for and fostering the
construction of the Space Center
building that we are did that we are
today dedicating to Ron's memory Charlie
I think all of us are curious about your
talk this morning its title man and
creation would seem to cover a lot of
territory so
thank you very much Gordon I am very
pleased to be here participate in this
occasion this is the honor dr. Ronald
McNair and dedicate the Ron McNair
building I never had an opportunity to
meet Ron McNair personally because I
know his work in laser physics and his
distinguished career as an astronaut but
there is also this other special reason
I feel the very close affinity for
McNair the NIR natives of this
relatively small state of South Carolina
we both have the red clay and the sand
of that state in our blood and I share
the communities and the atmosphere which
nurtured him of course being black he
had more external hurdles to overcome
than I did and I think we have to
respect him all the more for his
accomplishments Ron McNair his life and
the building which will be named for him
been dedicated understanding the broader
universe around us
that's an imposing assignment but it's
nevertheless not completely out of touch
with the reality to me it's always been
a profoundly challenging thought that we
here are the recent creation of the
universe seem to be able to understand
as much as we do about its workings and
its history we've discovered many
certainly not all of the processes which
long ago brought about our own creation
that's particularly fantastic that we
seem to have found there's clear
evidence which film is mentioned for the
very origins of our universe the Big
Bang going back in time some 10,000 fold
beyond the origin of anything resembling
ourselves and that this creatures mind
can begin to understand its own creation
is quite startling logical or not we
even presume that man's mind has a
chance of understanding itself one he is
increasing talk of the anthropic
principle at the laws of the universe
had to be almost precisely as they are
in order for anything like us to exist
on the one hand this can be taken just
as a tautology as we exist in this
universe it must be of a style so that
we can't exist it's obviously on the
other hand the existence of man clearly
required a particular arrangement of
universal laws and constants and even
their fine-tuning another startling
situation startling to me is that we now
find ourselves increasingly co-creators
in this universe Shakespeare's Hamlet
exclaimed what a piece of work is man
how noble in reason how infinite and
faculty and I don't think he was just
talking about the number of current
number of professors how infinite in
faculty in apprehension how like a god
and yet and he continued on and yet to
talk about some of his own personal
uncertainties so it's this infinite
faculty on which I want to comment but
also the end yet thought now in some
sense all parts of our universe interact
with each other and this interaction and
this that our interaction each plays its
role as a creator this is evident all
the way from the rather fuzzy principle
of Mark which says that the nature of
space must be determined by what's in it
to the detail and intricate role of each
bit player and forming and modifying its
own ecological surroundings and niche
nonetheless mankind shares an
increasingly larger role as creative
affecting not only his own life and
being but having evermore responsibility
for the nature of much of our planet
and we're about to launch in a new
responsibilities concerning both our own
nature through understanding of modern
molecular biology and genetic
engineering and through space
exploration even the larger universe
beyond our own planet now this is an
open universe the one for which the
future is not innately determined and
one in which through science and applied
science we are becoming more and more
these Co determinants of that future the
uncertainty principle which is
relatively new that has for some time
nevertheless freed us of any idea of a
complete determinism we still fail to
understand anything like free will well
nevertheless being instinctively
convinced that somehow we we possess it
in any case there's no doubt that the
effects of mankind's intellectual power
and his actions are playing an
increasingly powerful role in creating
this world around us and on the scale of
planets history even on the scale of
mankind's existence this role is rather
new and very rapidly accelerating I need
only be reminded that all of our written
history is no longer than about 70 human
lifetimes and modern experimental
science is perhaps no older than the
length of say five human lifetimes much
of a roll of this unusual creature man
comes through his understanding his
noble reason and how much terms and yet
and yet in spite of all our reason and
science our foresight as to what the
future holds in very important respects
fuzzy uncertain this part of the nature
of creation new ideas are indeed
unforeseen
shall we move headlong along and usually
with great anticipation into a world we
really don't yet know and certainly in
the struggle of creation is easily
illustrated
Lord Rayleigh the great English
physicist who should have understood
aerodynamics as well as anyone of his
time was quoted as saying quote I have
not the smallest molecule of faith in
any kind of aerial navigation other than
ballooning and this was only seven years
before the Wright brothers took off from
Kitty Hawk Lord Rutherford who was also
perhaps the outstanding expert on the
nucleus of his time was able to say
quote anyone who expects a source of
power from the transformation of these
atoms he's talking moonshine and this
only eight years before family produced
and his team produced the first
sustained hopefully reaction well hole
Committees of wise men have often been
no less fallible at the request of
President Franklin Roosevelt a
commission which can very reasonably be
said to represented a collection of the
best minds and the senior statesmen and
science and engineering of the time
tried to assess the future developments
in science and technology which might
affect American society and economy over
the subsequent decades their report
issued 1937 had some interesting things
to say but the most interesting is what
the distinguished commission members
missed because they list antibiotics
which had already been discovered but
weren't appreciated they missed nuclear
energy which came only four years later
they miss radar jet aircraft rockets
space exploration now chips or moon
computers solid-state electronics and
all of its ramifications lasers and
quantum electronics molecular biology
and of course modern genetic engineering
so it made a list for the most exciting
technical developments of the following
decades that's what they missed your
creation necessarily pushes us into the
unknown and often into controversy
frequently into danger Ron McNair
recognized and I think caught that very
well and his phrase hanging it over the
edge as it is the edge of the unknown
creativity also doesn't often come from
this
wisdom of the time and committees but
requires individuals more than you knew
more than usually devoted to an idea and
willing to accept uncertainties and
risks creation often depends on
individuals who are willing to take that
extra effort to be unusual to take these
risk Ron McNair was himself one of those
who had the intellectual and the
physical vigor and courage to go beyond
the ordinary to the extraordinary MIT is
of course provided its share of
creativity during the recent past and we
can look at those who associated with
the this building we talked about today
we've added to our understanding and the
world's new technology the people in
that building will be creating new
things which are different but which
nevertheless will parallel past
discoveries here discovery by Bruno
Rossi and his associates of x-ray
sources outside our solar system
distinguished work of George Clark in
this area discovery by Alan Barrett and
his associates of the first molecule in
space by radio techniques stock Draper's
very striking development of inertial
guidance her bridges sounding of
interplanetary plasmas Gordon Pettingill
first explorations of surface contours
of Venus all the exploration of human
physiology and space Larry young and his
associates now new knowledge has two
sides one basic science side is
primarily cultural in nature discovery
and understanding give us a breadth of
view and inspiration satisfaction of
innate wonder an intellectual drive and
a sense of creative achievement toward
some of our most Universal goals and
ideas which are really our most lasting
monuments but there is also the
application of knowledge particularly
scientific knowledge to individual and
social use which is technology
engineering these two sides are
certainly in modern times closely
knitted together and perhaps they always
were
they depend on each other in intimate
and crucial ways the importance of the
cultural aspect is no less real because
it's not so measurable in concrete
nevertheless it's clearly the
technological aspect which most directly
will be changing our lives I was a
graduate student when this Roosevelt
Commission made its report and
recognizing all that's happened in the
intervening 50 years one can wonder what
to expect 50 years from now when
now I'm a little confused
here we are what generally expect 50
years from now when the students here at
MIT today have an opportunity to look
back over their careers and over their
lifetime what will be those discoveries
of the future now my previous remarks
obviously I have to resist the any vain
attempt to make specific predictions
there clearly our fields were exciting
new discoveries is imminent one
concerning the ultimate and
microstructure of our universe
associated with particle physics another
the rapidly developing understanding of
biological systems in all their
intricacy and beauty including the
ultimate challenge the human mind
understand itself most pertinent to our
dedication today is the expiration of
the rest rest of the universe that is
the universe which is outside our own
planet at the same time so intimately
tied with its creation in history and
how are these new discoveries to come
about and where in fact is man as a
creator taking us I think there are two
extreme views towards this change and
towards the future one comes from fear
and uncertainty or at least reservation
about the beneficence of any change in
our society changing the things around
us this was constantly manifest in the
early days of exploration of our earth
when new territories will looked on not
only as barbarous and while but desolate
and useless Columbus for example was
called in his time the Lord of the
mosquitoes and it was really only about
a hundred years ago secretary Seward was
pressing the United States to purchase
Alaska
and being joked about and Alaska was
called Seward's icebox and Seward's
folly I think this type of you might be
cast in terms of
today is dedication by a story of a
little old lady who complained why does
everybody want to go off and explore
space why can't they just sit home and
watch TV like God intended at the other
end of the scale yes their flights of
fancy for example it was illustrated by
science fiction but uses magical ways
for everyday men and women that as if
back and forth across our galaxy and
visit multiple planets magic because
they defy basic scientific laws
somewhere in between these will see the
future clearly a creation of the future
must obey the laws of the universe but
within these limits of possible is
facing young people of today really
enormous
there's developments over the last 50
years certainly illustrate I believe
these possibilities are not going to be
defined by our cold calculations of what
we know how to do and can show is
practical and comfortable at this point
but rather they will ultimately be
determined probably by human aspirations
as much as anything it's partly for this
reason that science fiction which often
reflects humanity's dreams as elements
of truth impressions about the long-term
future which are completely missed by
many of the careful attempts to consider
present practicalities our aspirations
are critical for mankind's creations as
in this light that I expect most recent
report from the National Commission of
space is probably basically correct that
our species will be exploring space both
to understand what is there to make new
living and working areas for humans
Commission comments that the solar
system is our extended home proposes as
basic parts of space program that it
should advance understanding of our
planet our solar system and the universe
but also should explore prospect and
settle the solar system
is this a lot of practical perhaps not
certainly not immediately but it is
consonant with basic scientific laws and
a prominent aspect of mankind's
aspiration I believe such aspirations
are fundamental to the nature of man and
his role in this creation they already
say ascending brave pioneers in the
space and with time advancing human
knowledge and technology will make much
of what is difficult quite practical of
course there will be powerful changes
back here on earth our home base
associated with advancing technology
probably many of them quite surprising
there'll be major steps and the conquest
of pain disease hunger vision of inertia
pies and other facilities for increasing
mankind scope and activity and how
wonderfully each of us can think of this
envisage new creation increase human
capacities and progress mankind how
infinite in capacity how infinite in
faculties and yet and yet there are also
aspects of man's creations and
aspirations which hang over us like a
cloud they raise critical questions
about the value of our creations even
the viability of the species questions
which might variously be called moral
ethical religious or perhaps
philosophical there's what we really all
about what kind of responsibility have
we as individuals always a group towards
this participation in creation what kind
of relations and what kind of
organizations do we establish for this
generation of humans
what kind of economics politics human
freedom or personal attitudes towards
others and is of course the question of
war but there is much more there is this
noble reason than man's understanding
provides additional power over our
environment and over our fellow
creatures what type of responsibility do
we accept for them or presently for the
rest of the universe as we understand
and can increasingly modify biological
systems
including the human species itself how
well-prepared are we to have these new
powers fit into some ultimate scheme of
responsibilities specifically what
striking new technological breakthroughs
will occur as never clearly foreseeable
yet the general direction of science is
quite clear that is the direction of
increasing power and hence increasing
responsibility and ever more urgency and
these ultimate questions of who we think
we are and what our real aspirations and
prospects as a species these are really
troubling and difficult questions that
they are not new but they become more
poignant than ever
creation has its real dangers these
questions are certainly not new to MIT
which has been notably involved in
problems of society humane use of
Technology MIT also provides an
exceptional atmosphere for the interplay
of ideas from disciplines different
disciplines and of the academic with a
practical so it's a good place for this
laboratory and for the exploration of
our universe and man's future because
such questions and considerations were
also clearly prominent in Ron McNair
thought and his own deep religious
commitment as we renamed this important
laboratory to honor him let's also honor
his aspirations and the appeal which is
expressed here the booklet you have is
appeal which in his word says truly
there is no more beautiful sight than to
see the Earth from space beyond this
planet is an exquisite oasis want
emanates from the earth when you look at
her from space my wish is that we would
allow this planet to be the beautiful
Oasis that years and allow ourselves to
live more in the piece that she
generates
[Applause]
our third speaker this morning is dr.
George Carruthers senior astrophysicist
at the Naval Research Laboratory in
Washington DC
following the receipt of his PhD from
the University of Illinois in 1964 he
joined the naval research laboratory
where he remains today I was interested
to note that from his biography like
myself and others at MIT he had training
in nuclear physics at one time which he
has abandoned in favor of the wide
horizons of astronomy dr. Carruthers is
widely known and respected for his
research in ultraviolet astronomy
received the Warner Prize for this work
from the American Astronomical Society
in 1973 far ultraviolet is far
ultraviolet astronomy requires an
observing platform well above Earth's
atmosphere
otherwise the Rays are absorbed and it
was this requirement that made it
natural for him to call on his training
and Astronautics engineering and place
instruments in space using both
suborbital rocket flights as well as
Earth orbiting spacecraft dr. Carruthers
has been an active participant in the
National Science establishment having
served on various boards of the National
Academy of Sciences and NASA and he has
been especially active in the affairs of
the National Technical Association a
professional Society for minority
scientists and engineers in which he
also plays a very strong role currently
as editor of the NTA Journal this
morning he will describe the future of a
star of astronomy from space dr.
Carruthers
morning I'm very thankful and honored to
be here today and to participate in this
dedication ceremony in honor of dr.
Ronald McNair I regret that I never had
the opportunity to meet Ron personally
although I had heard much about his
remarkable accomplishments and I'm
thankful that I had the opportunity to
meet some of his family and some of
those who went to school with him when
he was here at MIT today I'm going to be
talking about the future of astronomy
from space I might mention that that was
one of the major objectives of the
shuttle mission in which he glass flew
which had an objective to observe comet
Halley which returns to the vicinity of
the earth every 76 years
astronomy is the study of objects
outside of the earth is Professor
Morrison mentioned such as the Sun
planets stars and galaxies and differs
from other physical sciences in that
it's measurements are obtained mainly by
remote sensing of electromagnetic
radiation which is emitted from or
reflected from the object under study
rather than by direct experimentation or
Institue measurements by sending a
sample to the chemist if I could have
the first slide and the lights down
what we are showing here is the range of
the electromagnetic spectrum one
normally observes visible light which
ranges from the red to the blue but
that's only a very small portion of the
entire range of the electromagnetic
spectrum which ranges from extremely
high-energy x-rays and gamma rays
through the ultraviolet through the
visible and through the infrared and
down to the long wavelength radio
radiation one of the problems is that
classical astronomy has been limited to
those wavelength ranges which penetrate
the Earth's atmosphere that's basically
only the visual range and the radio
range large portions of the infrared
radiation and almost all of the
ultraviolet x-ray and gamma-ray
radiation is totally blocked by the
Earth's atmosphere and therefore is
totally inaccessible to ground-based
telescopes
therefore astronomy has been the science
which is benefited perhaps most from
space-based observations now this next
slide shows in more detail what I was
mentioning previously that the visible
range and the radio range penetrate down
to sea level and therefore ground-based
optical telescopes and radio telescopes
are quite productive but in order to
observe in the ultraviolet and the x-ray
ranges one has to go to extremely high
altitudes above 100 miles altitude
typically in order to observe mostly
radiation coming in from
extraterrestrial objects in the infrared
where a little bit better off in that
substantial improvements can be obtained
by observing in aircraft and balloons at
high altitudes above the lower
atmosphere but even in this case we
benefit greatly by going into orbit with
our instrumentation now there are a
number of reasons why access to these
new ranges of the spectrum are important
one of the basic reasons is that as
professor Morrison mentioned we can
analyze the light coming from
extraterrestrial objects to determine
their composition and many of the common
materials such as oxygen hydrogen and so
forth are totally transparent to visual
light and therefore you can't detect
them by looking in visual wavelength
ranges by going into the ultraviolet
into the infrared the spectral
signatures of these common atoms and
molecules can be more readily studied in
extraterrestrial objects the second very
important reason is that the wavelength
of radiation is related to temperature
as in the case of a simple blackbody
radiator which is not really a
representative detail of what we would
expect to see from stars and other
planets but gives a simple analogy
ordinary visible light which is here
corresponds to objects and temperature
ranges between 3,000 degrees Kelvin and
10,000 degrees Kelvin in which the
radiator has its maximum efficiency the
total intensity of radiation increases
very rapidly with temperature but what
is perhaps even more significant is that
the peak the maximum of the radiation is
wavelength is temperature dependent so
for objects that are much cooler than
the Sun for example even a tungsten
light bulb which is as temperature about
3,000 degrees Kelvin is very inefficient
at radiating visible light and that's
why we want to go to fluorescent
lighting where possible because it's
more efficient but objects even cooler
than that emit primarily in the infrared
and that's why they don't emit physical
light room-temperature objects have
their peak radiation at 10 microns in
the infrared and even cooler objects
like 30 degrees Kelvin which is the
temperature that we see in some regions
of dense interstellar gas and dust
clouds have their peak radiation at 100
microns in the infrared
likewise extremely hot objects such as
very hot stars and x-ray sources you met
most of their radiation at wavelengths
well below the atmospheric cutoff at
three thousand angstroms and therefore
it's very important to get
instrumentation above the atmosphere
and/or
to get more comprehensive observations
of these objects now what we have shown
here is a series of planned space
missions that NASA calls its great
Observatory series the Hubble Space
Telescope which I will mention a little
bit more about a little later operates
in the visual range and also in the
ultraviolet the planned astronomical
x-ray astrophysics facility makes
observations in the x-ray range which
corresponds to very high temperature
phenomena in the temperature ranges of
millions of degrees on the other hand
the shuttle in space infrared telescope
facility will be operating in the
infrared and will be making measurements
of temperature regimes on the order of a
hundred degrees Kelvin or much lower
than room temperature and will observe
such things as interstellar gas and dust
which are totally invisible to
ground-based telescopes operating in
visible light and at the extreme high
energy range the gamma ray Observatory
will observe even the very highest
energy phenomena in the universe such as
nuclear reactions between protons and
antiprotons things like that so you see
that in order to really get a complete
study of phenomena in the universe you
have to operate over a wide wavelength
range because if you only look in one
wavelength range such as the visual you
would only see a certain temperature
range if you only operated at very high
energies you'd see certain other types
of phenomena and same thing if you
operate in the infrared you see totally
different phenomena there so in order to
get the entire picture you really have
to have instrumentation operating over a
very wide range of the electromagnetic
spectrum red speaker this morning is dr.
George Carruthers senior astrophysicist
at the Naval Research Laboratory in
Washington DC
following the receipt of his PhD from
the University of Illinois in 1964 he
joined the naval research laboratory
where he remains
today I was interested to note that from
his biography like myself and others at
MIT he had training in nuclear physics
at one time which he has abandoned in
favor of the wide horizons of astronomy
dr. Carruthers is widely known and
respected for his research in
ultraviolet astronomy and received the
Warner Prize for this work from the
American Astronomical Society in 1973
far ultra vires as far altra violet
astronomy requires an observing platform
well above Earth's atmosphere otherwise
the rays are absorbed and it was this
requirement that made it natural for him
to call on his training and Astronautics
engineering and place instruments in
space using both suborbital rocket
flights as well as Earth orbiting
spacecraft dr. Carruthers has been an
active participant in the National
Science establishment having served on
various boards of the National Academy
of Sciences and NASA and he has been
especially active in the affairs of the
National Technical Association a
professional Society for minority
scientists and engineers in which he
also plays a very strong role currently
as editor of the NTA journal this
morning he will describe the future of a
star of astronomy from space dr.
Carruthers
morning I'm very thankful and honored to
be here today and to participate in this
dedication ceremony in honor of dr.
Ronald McNair I regret that I never had
the opportunity to meet Braun personally
although I had heard much about his
remarkable accomplishments and I'm
thankful that I had the opportunity to
meet some of his family and some of
those who went to school with him when
he was here at MIT today I'm going to be
talking about the future of astronomy
from space I might mention that that was
one of the major objectives of the
shuttle mission in which he glass flew
which had an objective to observe comet
Halley which returns to the vicinity of
the earth every 76 years
astronomy is the study of objects
outside of the earth is professor
Morrison mentioned such as the Sun
planets stars and galaxies and differs
from other physical sciences in that
it's measurements are obtained mainly by
remote sensing of electromagnetic
radiation which is emitted from or
reflected from the object under study
rather than by direct experimentation or
in situ measurements by sending a sample
to the chemist if I could have the first
slide and the lights down
what we are showing here is the range of
the electromagnetic spectrum one
normally observes visible light which
ranges from the red to the blue but
that's only a very small portion of the
entire range of the electromagnetic
spectrum which ranges from extremely
high-energy x-rays and gamma rays
through the ultraviolet through the
visible and through the infrared and
down to the long wavelength radio
radiation one of the problems is that
classical astronomy has been limited to
those wavelength ranges which penetrate
the Earth's atmosphere that's basically
only the visual range and the radio
range large portions of the infrared
radiation and almost all of the
ultraviolet x-ray and gamma-ray
radiation is totally blocked by the
Earth's atmosphere and therefore is
totally inaccessible to ground-based
telescopes
therefore astronomy has been the science
which is benefited perhaps most from
space-based observations now this next
slide shows in more detail what I was
mentioning previously that the visible
range and the radio range penetrate down
to sea level and therefore ground-based
optical telescopes and radio telescopes
are quite productive but in order to
observe in the ultraviolet and the x-ray
ranges one has to go to extremely high
altitudes above 100 miles the altitude
typically in order to observe most the
radiation coming in from
extraterrestrial objects in the infrared
we're a little bit better off in that
substantial improvements can be obtained
by observing in aircraft and balloons at
high altitudes above the lower
atmosphere but even in this case we
benefit greatly by going into orbit with
our instrumentation now there are a
number of reasons why access to these
new ranges of the spectrum are important
one of the basic reasons is that as
Professor Morrison mentioned we can
analyze the light coming from
extraterrestrial objects
to determine their composition and many
of the common materials such as oxygen
hydrogen and so forth are totally
transparent to visual light and
therefore you can't detect them by
looking in visual wavelength ranges by
going into the ultraviolet into the
infrared the spectral signatures of
these common atoms and molecules can be
more readily studied in extraterrestrial
objects the second very important reason
is that the wavelength of radiation is
related to temperature as in the case of
a simple blackbody radiator which is not
really a representative detail of what
we would expect to see from stars and
other planets but gives a simple analogy
ordinary visible light which is here
corresponds to objects and temperature
ranges between 3,000 degrees Kelvin and
10,000 degrees Kelvin in which the
radiator has its maximum efficiency the
total intensity of radiation increases
very rapidly with temperature but what
is perhaps even more significant is that
the peak the maximum of the radiation is
wavelength is temperature dependent
so for objects that are much cooler than
the Sun for example even a tungsten
light bulb which is as temperature about
3,000 degrees Kelvin is very inefficient
at radiating visible light and that's
why we want to go to fluorescent
lighting where possible because it's
more efficient but objects even cooler
than that emit primarily in the infrared
and that's why they don't emit physical
light room-temperature objects have
their peak radiation at 10 microns in
the infrared and even cooler objects
like 30 degrees Kelvin which is the
temperature that we see in some regions
of dense interstellar gas and dust
clouds have their peak radiation at 100
microns in the infrared
likewise extremely hot objects such as
very hot stars and x-ray sources you met
most of their radiation at wavelengths
well below the atmospheric cutoff at
three thousand angstroms and therefore
it's very important to get
instrumentation above the atmosphere in
order to get more concrete
observations of these objects now what
we have shown here is a series of
planned space missions that NASA calls
its great Observatory series the hubble
space telescope which i will mention a
little bit more about a little later
operates in the visual range and also in
the ultraviolet the planned astronomical
x-ray astrophysics facility makes
observations in the x-ray range which
corresponds to very high temperature
phenomena in the temperature ranges of
millions of degrees on the other hand
the shuttle in space infrared telescope
facility will be operating in the
infrared and will be making measurements
of temperature regimes on the order of a
hundred degrees Kelvin or much lower
than room temperature and will observe
such things as interstellar gas and dust
which are totally invisible to
ground-based telescopes operating in
visible light and at the extreme high
energy range the gamma ray Observatory
will observe even the very highest
energy phenomena in the universe such as
nuclear reactions between protons and
antiprotons things like that so you see
that in order to really get a complete
study of phenomena in the universe you
have to operate over a wide wavelength
range because if you only look in one
wavelength range such as the visual you
would only see a certain temperature
range if you only operate at very high
energies you would see certain other
types of phenomena and same thing if you
operate in the infrared you see totally
different phenomena there so in order to
get the entire picture you really have
to have instrumentation operating over a
very wide range of the electromagnetic
spectrum now what are the things that
astronomers really want to find out
after all when we go to Congress to
justify new space missions the first
thing they say well you've got these
telescopes at Mount Palomar that got the
ground-based Very Large Array telescope
why do you need Space Telescope why do
you need all of these other things
the problem is that there are still very
important questions they are not yet
answered about how the universe began
how galaxies formed how stars and
planets formed and even the question of
how life began and as you can see the
modern field of astrophysics involves
not just physics but also chemistry and
even biology and these are all very
fundamental questions of great
importance to our whole society now let
me go on into a little bit more detail
on some of these wavelength ranges as
dr. Pettingill mentioned my involvement
has been in the ultraviolet astronomy
area and I'll just give a few examples
of how that provides new information
that we wouldn't have otherwise on the
right here is a ground-based visible
light picture of the constellation of
Orion which is now prominent in the
eastern sky right after sunset and it's
a prominent feature in the night sky
because it contains a large number of
very bright and luminous young stars
many of these stars are much hotter than
our Sun with temperatures of thirty
thousand degrees Kelvin or more five
times the temperature of our Sun which
is six thousand degrees Kelvin and
therefore most of their radiation is in
the ultraviolet wavelength range on the
other hand there are also many other
cooler stars which are more like our Sun
and perhaps most prominent to the visual
to the unaided eye is the bright red
giant star Betelgeuse which is cooler
than our Sun but very much larger and
therefore more luminous now on the left
is a photograph obtained in far
ultraviolet light with one of our
instruments carried on a sounding rocket
flight in 1975 which shows that the very
hot stars are much more prominent in the
ultraviolet than they are in a visible
whereas the cooler stars for example
Betelgeuse is totally absent in the
to picture now what's perhaps even more
significant than observations of nearby
constellations such as this is when one
goes to external galaxies this is the
nearest external galaxy the Large
Magellanic Cloud which unfortunately is
not visible from the northern hemisphere
but on the left this time as a
ground-based visual light photograph and
on the right is an ultraviolet
photograph which we obtained with an
instrument on the Apollo 16 mission in
1972 and the ultraviolet imagery shows
that the distribution of the very hot
stars is quite different from the
distribution of the cooler stars which
are prominent in the ground-based
photograph and since normally in
external galaxies one cannot resolve
individual stars it's much more
practical to have a survey such as this
which shows immediately where these
stars are located then trying to examine
each and every image of a ground-based
photograph to try to decide which ones
are hot stars which ones are cooler now
in order to study hot stars in more
detail nASA has launched a series of
unmanned observatories beginning in 1968
the orbiting astronomical observatory
series oils
2 and 3 and also the International
ultraviolet Explorer satellite launched
in 1978 which is still in operation and
which provides much more detailed
spectroscopic information as opposed to
the direct imagery that I showed in the
first two slides and they have made
measurements of interstellar gas
hydrogen oxygen molecular hydrogen
carbon monoxide things of this nature
which are undetectable with ground-based
telescopes
going to higher energies into the x-ray
range this is a picture of a large area
x-ray detector which the Naval Research
Laboratory provided for the first
high-energy astronomical observatory
which was launched in 1977 I believe and
what we see here is a quite different
map of the sky in x-ray radiation from
what we see an ordinary visible light as
I mentioned the x-rays are emitted by
extremely high energy and high
temperature processes and these
corresponds to such things as the active
nuclei of galaxies which are shown
color-coded as yellow supernova remnants
which are the remnants of exploding
stars such as the Crab Nebula which I'll
show you a picture of in a second binary
x-ray sources which include extremely
compact objects like neutron stars and
black holes which cause gas to be drawn
into them and when they collide and form
an accretion disk they produce
temperatures and many millions of
degrees which are extremely powerful
sources of x-rays and there are several
other types of sources which are shown
here
now the second high-energy astronomical
observatory which is shown here provide
more detailed imagery of specific
objects and also spectroscopy and x-ray
radiation and I believe people here at
MIT had some involvement with this
Observatory and it uses what is called a
grazing instance telescope which is
quite different from the ordinary types
of telescopes that one uses invisible
and in the ultraviolet and it had
several types of detectors and imaging
proportional counter and a crystal
spectrometer among other things which
were used to study the images of objects
and also their spectral distribution in
the x-ray region the x-ray advanced
x-ray astrophysics facility will be a
larger version but otherwise very
similar to the heal to spacecraft which
was called Einstein
the Crab Nebula is what we call a
supernova remnant the remains of a
massive star which exploded in 1054 ad
at the time of the explosion it was so
bright that it could be seen to the
naked eye and daytime all that is left
now is this expanding cloud of gas and a
compact neutron star which is a
collapsed core of the star no it took
quite a few years before astronomers
really understood what the neutron star
was and it turns out that it's quite
visible in this picture is just a nobody
recognized it until they found out that
it was pulsating at 30 times per second
and it was quite accidental that they
discovered that pulsation in visible
light although it had been known
previously in the radio and also occurs
in the x-ray range and the co2 Einstein
imaging Porsche counter gave this image
of the central region of the Crab Nebula
showing the neutron star remnant and
this cloud of x-ray emitting gas which
is excited by high-energy electrons
produced by the collapsing and rapidly
rotating neutron star so those are just
some examples of the kinds of things
that we have found out now going to the
other end of the spectrum in 1983 NASA
launched the infrared astronomical
satellite which made the first
measurements and the first Sky Survey in
the infrared spectral region which
provides information about star
formation and cold concentrations of gas
and dust I won't go through the details
of how this was put together but in
order to explore very cold objects you
have to have a very cold telescope this
cool this telescope is cooled to the
temperature of liquid helium which is
about four degrees above zero absolute
the reason of course is that it's
analogous to trying to observe stars in
visible light with a red-hot telescope
you have to have the telescope cooler
than what you're looking at in order to
make effective opera observations
this is a constellation of Orion again
just to orient you as to what it looks
like in the visible you'll notice that
there is a somewhat deficiency of stars
in this region here which is due to a
dense cloud of gas and dust but when
this is looked at with the IRS that
light we find that this dust is quite
luminous in the infrared even though
it's very cold the red color here
indicates material at temperatures on
the order of 30 degrees Kelvin whereas
the blue region up here corresponds to
hotter dust which exists within our own
solar system the region of gas and dust
in the solar system which is responsible
for the so called zodiacal light but
what we're really interested in here is
that this interstellar material is quite
prominent in the infrared
despite its extremely low temperature
and one of the most important objectives
of the RS satellite was to observe
regions in which new stars are forming
such as the region of the Orion Nebula
which is prominent in the visual also
but regions of star formation cannot be
observed in the visual because not only
the low temperature under which this
process occurs but also because it's
hidden by the dense clouds of gas and
dust which are totally opaque in the
visual but which are transparent in the
infrared this is another example looking
toward the center of our galaxy the
center of our galaxy's about 30,000
light years away and it's totally hidden
by dense clouds of intervening gas and
dust which the visual light cannot
penetrate we can only see that there is
a denser region of stars in that general
direction but in the infrared where we
can see through that we can see the all
the way through to the core of our
galaxy which is quite prominent in the
infrared and we can also see all of
these regions of newly forming stars
scattered along the plane of our galaxy
the advantages of space observations
that I've mentioned up to this point
have concentrated on the availability of
a wider range of the electromagnetic
spectrum however there is another very
important advantage of going out into
space and that is that we are freed from
the obscuring and distorting effects of
the Earth's atmosphere on astronomical
observations many amateur astronomers
don't realize it but the largest
ground-based telescope like the five
meter or 200-inch telescope at Mount
Palomar does not provide any better
resolution than a moderate sized amateur
telescope of 12 to 16 inches aperture
and the reason is that the distorting
effects of the Earth's atmosphere blur
the images to typical resolutions not
better than one second of Arc one second
of Arc is about 1800 the size of the
full moon and angular size and
corresponds to the size of a dime seen
at a distance of two miles
it sounds like good resolution but it
really isn't when you consider the
capabilities of a large telescope from
fundamental optical principles by going
out into space we can greatly improve
the resolution by freeing ourselves of
these distorting effects of the Earth's
atmosphere
the Hubble Space Telescope which is
shown in diagram here is very similar to
a typical ground-based telescope and in
fact it's not really very large it's
only a little less than three meters in
aperture which is well it's it's 2.4
meters in aperture which is almost
exactly half the aperture or 1/4 the
collecting area of the Palomar telescope
however because it's out in space and
free of the distorting effects of the
atmosphere it will achieve a angular
resolution of better than 0.1 arc
seconds a tenth of an arc second or ten
times better than the largest
ground-based telescope also because of
this better image resolution it will be
much more sensitive
to studies of astronomical sources paint
a particularly faint point sources like
stars so be able to observe a particular
brightness of star to the seven times
greater distance than the largest
ground-based telescope
the Space Telescope will be carried into
orbit by the space shuttle and will be
deployed and as shown here will operate
unmanned for periods of up through five
years before it's revisited by the
shuttle to change our instrumentation
and during the time that it's free
flying in orbit it transmits its data to
tracking and data relay satellite which
then in turn transmits the data to
ground-based ground stations I mentioned
that the resolution of the space
telescope is 10 times better than
typical ground-based and this gives you
an example of what this means this is a
picture of a nearby external galaxy
taken with a large ground-based
telescope and the detail that we will be
able to obtain in a nearby galaxy will
be comparable to the detail provided by
the ground-based telescope in our own
galaxy factors of 10 are quite important
in astronomy this is the Andromeda
galaxy which is the nearest large spiral
galaxy very similar to our own in size
and shape it's at a distance of about
two million light years and large
ground-based telescopes can just barely
resolve the individual stars in this
galaxy actually even a star as faint as
our Sun is invisible at the distance of
the Andromeda galaxy with present
ground-based equipment however there are
a number of types of stars which can be
observed in nearby external galaxies
which astronomers have found form
important distance indicators a so
called Cepheid variable stars the
absolute brightnesses of these stars are
known to a fair degree of accuracy from
observations of them in our own galaxy
so by observing these stars in other
galaxies we can determine the distance
since we know how bright they are
however ground-based telescopes
even galaxies ten times as far away as
the Andromeda galaxy is getting close to
the limit of what some of these distance
indicators are useful for in terms of
determining the distance of these
galaxies if we go by the shapes of
galaxies and their types we can get some
idea of distances out to perhaps a
hundred million light-years or about 50
times as far away as the Andromeda
galaxy so you can see there are various
types of galaxies such as spiral
galaxies and the elliptical galaxies and
various types of galaxies by knowing the
statistics on their sizes and shapes we
can get some idea of how far away they
are but if we go even another factor of
10 in distance to about the ultimate
limit of the ground-based telescopes
this is about a distance of 1 billion
light-years although you can see that
these galaxies are not stars they're
just fuzzy blobs and you really can't
say much more than that now why is this
an important problem if you recall that
the speed of light is the limiting
factor a galaxy at a distance of 1
billion light years shows us what the
universe was like 1 billion years ago
because that's when the light left there
however astronomers estimate the age of
the universe to be somewhere between 10
and 15 billion years so what we really
want to do is be able to observe objects
at 10 or 15 billion years light years
distance so we can really understand how
the university fall and you can see
we're a long way from that goal the
Hubble Space Telescope will help us
quite a bit because another factor of 10
will apply to all of the previous slides
that I just showed you will be able to
detect objects such as this out to 10
billion light years instead of 1 billion
the previous slide will be able to
obtain detailed studies of galaxies out
to 1 billion light years and objects in
which we can study individual stars 2
ten million light years 100 million
light years rather okay now let me go on
to some of the other things that are
proposed the infrared astronomical
satellite had a lifetime of only nine
months because of the fact that it had a
limited supply of liquid helium also
there are a number of improvements that
we can make for more detailed
observations in their infrared so one of
the highest priority missions of NASA is
the space infrared telescope facility
which is an expanded version of the IR s
and also has the capability of being
revisited by the shuttle so the liquid
helium coolant can be replenished it
will be able to observe much fainter
objects than the IR s satellite and will
be able to obtain much better imaging
and spectral detail I've already
mentioned that other future observations
include the advanced x-ray astrophysics
facility which will provide similar
increments and capability over the po2
Einstein Observatory and the gamma ray
Observatory which will make the first
high-energy very high-energy
observations over the whole sky which
will be launched hopefully in 1990 now
in addition to these great observatories
the future of space astronomy will
depend to a large degree on much smaller
and much less expensive individual
experiments carried on the space shuttle
and perhaps installed on the space
station individual small astronomical
experiments can make particular
contributions in areas in which the
Space Telescope and other facilities
which are general-purpose are not
optimized for example the Space Lab
version of Shuttle missions allows one
to carry small telescopes such as this
solar telescope that was on the Space
Lab to Mission for observations
the Sun stars and other objects in
particular wavelength ranges which are
not dressed by the Great observatories
and also the fact that we have manned
involvement in the Space Lab mission
makes them much more flexible and
capable than an unmanned satellite for
many purposes another type of small
experiment is the so called Spartan this
was the Spartan one which was carried by
the shuttle into orbit in the spring of
1985 and this had an x-ray astronomy
experiment on it and there are several
other Spartan satellites in the series
of observations planned for the future
so with that I would like to conclude by
saying that those of us who are in the
astronomical field are looking forward
to the advances in our knowledge which
will provide it be provided by
space-based observations over the coming
decade to a large extent the Space
Shuttle will be a primary tool for
carrying out these carrying these
instruments into space and as a base of
observations maintenance and retrieval
and I and most others in the
astronomical field are very excited by
these coming attractions thank you
thank you very much dr. Carruthers I
think you've made the case for the
measurement of a strong astronomy from
space very strongly but I'm probably
biased so the final speaker this morning
is dr. Byron Lichtenberg who's also an
MIT product having done both his
undergraduate and graduate work here he
received a doctorate in biomedical
engineering as a hertz fellow in 1979
and in the same year began his
involvement with several vestibular
experiments which were conceived and
constructed by scientists and engineers
in both the man vehicle laboratory and
the MIT Center for Space Research
dr. Lichtenberg executed these
experiments aboard the space lab one
mission as payload specialists in 1983
as a background as a pilot in the Air
Force where he's been twice awarded the
Distinguished Flying Cross as well as
many air medals and he brings a
different perspective to this morning's
discussion he's actually been out there
in space and he can describe that
feeling firsthand please dr. Litton berg
tell us what it's like
Thank You Gordon the McNair family it's
really an honor for me to be here and
participate in these dedication
ceremonies today I would like to stress
a little bit more people in space ron
was out there he knew what it was like
and what I'd like to try and do in some
small measure today is give you a little
bit of an idea about it's about what
it's like
although Ron and I worked here at MIT
and we were somewhat in close proximity
we never met here we met after he was
taken into the astronaut program as a
mission specialist and I've talked to
him briefly several times and when I did
that his enthusiasm for space his love
of exploration and his love of education
certainly came through I've heard him
give several speeches including one to
the Massachusetts legislature in which
he pleaded for more support for
education and that also applies to
higher education such as places at MIT
and I certainly heartily concur with his
feelings in those areas what I'd like to
do today is give you a little bit of my
impressions of spaceflight and people up
there what they're doing why we're going
out there I would like to try and put it
in the context of the types of things
that we can do in space then I'd like to
give you a brief idea about where we are
hopefully going in the future in terms
of people in space science in space and
a wide variety of humanity in space
finally closing with a few slides of the
Earth from space and give you a few of
my personal recollections and probably
some of the things that will be similar
to what you've heard Ron say in the past
about the perceptual changes the things
that come over you once you've flown in
space because it certainly does make a
difference so what I'd like to do is
start with several slides I am picking
up the slides of our particular flight
of space lab one back in December of
November in December of 1983 and I
wanted to start out by giving you a
feeling for what the Space Lab is it is
a pressurized module that sits in the
back of the Space Shuttle Orbiter and it
also encompasses pallets of science
equipment as dr. Carruthers showed you a
minute ago alike
Space Lab two experiments now this
particular piece of equipment was built
by the European Space Agency it was
designed to be able to act like a
laboratory in space so that people could
go up there work in a short-sleeve
environment as you would work in the
laboratories in the Ron McNair building
for example to send active participating
scientists up into space to do their
particular experiments just to prove to
you that we really did go up there some
people still think it's done in a movie
set this is the Space Lab on our flight
in the back of the shuttle you can see
it fills the entire diameter of the
cargo bay it's attached to the mid-deck
area of the orbiter with a tunnel so
that we have free and easy access in a
short-sleeve environment to go in there
to do our particular science experiments
now on every flight we have a wide
variety of people our flight was
certainly no exception we had two pilots
who actually fly the vehicle - mission
specialists Ron McNair was a mission
specialist career NASA astronauts people
who are scientists and systems engineers
to run the vehicle and to do the
experiments and to carry out a wide
variety of duties on board we also had
two of us payload specialists I was
extremely fortunate to be one of those
payload specialists chosen by the
science community we also had a European
onboard doctor Rolf Mayer bold who was a
materials scientist from Germany and
chosen by the European Space Agency and
also by the scientists that had
particular experiments on this flight
give you an idea of what it looks like
inside it really is a true laboratory we
have a series of racks similar to the
19-inch racks that we have here in the
laboratories at MIT it's a very roomy
spacious place to work it gives you a
great feeling and it's so great that
you're actually floating in air here as
you can see it it's a tremendous
experience to be up there and to to be
able to work in space the only regret
that I had was that we didn't have
enough time to look outside and see the
earth and I'll try and remedy that when
I get to my earth slides and in a minute
there have been four Spacelab missions
that have flown so far we flew in a 19-8
three we had Space Lab 3 which was
designed solely to look at material
sciences experiments a few life sciences
in 1985 Space Lab two also in the summer
of 1985 to look at solar astronomy and
physics and the German Space Lab mission
in November of 1985 again looking at
material science life sciences and some
navigation experiments but for Space Lab
one we were really a demonstration
flight our goal was to prove the Space
Lab system and to do that we conducted
experiments in many different science
disciplines I'm going to stress some of
the life sciences ones today because
we're talking about humans in space
we're talking about having people up
there and as I look at the space program
and starting from a child reading
science fiction that dr. Townes talked
about earlier at that time it was
science fiction people were not going
into space we didn't have people in
orbit and we didn't have satellites
going to the planets it was really
science fiction and we've been able to
make that come a reality and as you're
well aware it sometimes takes a lot of
sacrifice for that to happen in the
Space Lab we can do a variety of
experiments we were busy growing plants
miniature sunflower seeds to look at how
they react to the weightless environment
of space there many things that need to
be done in plant growth in the future we
need to understand the basic mechanisms
the way plants sense gravity and this
gives us a more basic understanding of
the physiology in the plants but even in
a more practical sense we need to
understand how we can grow generations
of plants in space without degradation
because surely someday as you've heard
and will continue to hear our vision is
in the Stars our future is there we're
going there and we need to take our
grocery store with us and to do that we
need to be able to grow plants in space
to give us food to give us atmosphere
revitalization and to recycle water as
well as aesthetic pleasing environment
up there which is important to all of us
in the in the areas of human physiology
things that are of interest now
primarily in a science sense are those
areas of cardiovascular physiology
looking at the heart the blood system
the musculoskeletal system we did a
variety of experiments looking at these
changes and just to kind of tantalize
you a little bit I'll tell you that
although the changes are not really
severe and they are reversible strange
things happen for example in space you
lose between fifteen and twenty percent
of your blood volume over seven to ten
days in space now that levels out and
it's not a problem for long-duration
flight but there are problems and things
that happen with the musculoskeletal
system the muscles get weakened atrophy
your bones start to demineralize they
start to decalcify and in fact we lose
something like 1% of calcium a month as
we stay in orbit so we need to better
understand these things if we're going
to make these dreams a reality and we
need to start doing the research as you
can see now and we've been doing it we
also our subjects as well as experiment
operators and as you can see here we
were doing some investigations into the
blood system I turned out to be not only
a biomedical engineer and an earth
observer and an astronomer and a space
plasma physicist but also a blood donor
and a lab technician all those in space
so you can see that we really gave of
ourselves to go up there and to be able
to look into these particular areas of
physiological interest we also did some
human perceptual experiments where we're
looking at changes that occur in how you
sense your limb position and limb motion
can you do the same types of tasks do
you have the same accuracies of
pointing or of estimating weights or
masses in space as we do here on the
ground so we did several of these
experiments as well
shaking small gray balls of different
masses to be able to detect how large a
difference we could observe in space in
the field which is more my specialty
vestibular physiology looking at the the
way the human reinterprets the sensory
sensations in space the sensory changes
that occur the MIT group along with
Canadians had a series of experiments
looking at space motion sickness
again it's not a long-term problem but
it affects close to 70% of the people
that go into orbit for 3 to 4 days
during each flight and while it's not
totally debilitating it can slow you
down at Ken Mario performance somewhat
and it's something we need to understand
more about so we conducted a series of
experiments again as operators and test
subjects to look at the inner ear system
the organs of balance and what happens
to those when you in fact have a fall in
space that we create artificially here
or what happens when you move somebody
in space another set of experiments
designed to look at the sensitivities of
the inner ear and in fact what happens
over 5 to 10 days is that the brain
changes it's adaptable it starts
realizing that there is no longer
gravity pulling you down we can't use
gravity up there as any orientation cue
the brain starts to rely more heavily on
the eyes on the visual system so we
wanted to see what it did with this
motion sensing system so we would
provide motions we also had helmets and
visual displays to provide a wide
variety of visual stimuli to look at
again how the brain reorganizes and how
it reacts to that brand-new environment
that we've never experienced before
well there are other areas also we did a
credible amount of experiments in
material science growing new types of
crystals new alloys investigating the
basic physical properties of what
happens to fluids and solids in space
and how you can possibly come up with
new concoctions we also used the Space
Lab as a control system for many outside
payloads the telescope's you saw earlier
and dr. Caruthers talk on space lab -
were controlled from computers inside
the Space Shuttle and inside the Space
Lab system parts we also use many
control systems to look at a variety of
areas we had experiments as I said
before in astronomy and solar physics
and earth observations and plasma
physics and I'd like to show you a slide
of very interesting plasma physics
demonstration this is not blood plasma
now but this is space plasma this is
ionized gases and particles this is a
beautiful picture of an Aurora taken
from the Space Lab three mission
the South Pole so we can't call it the
Northern Lights have to call it the I
guess southern aurora borealis but you
can get an idea of the beauty even at
night of a very large-scale aurora this
is stretching all the way across the
horizon from the vantage point of the
shuttle you can see very many cloud
features the energy released in this is
just phenomenal I'd like to point out
also how thin and fragile our atmosphere
is this little brown band just that wide
is all of our atmosphere it's very
striking when you see that the first
time from space even with your naked eye
and you realize that being up only 125
to 130 miles that you're above virtually
all of it and looking down and realize
that that's what's taking care of our
entire planet some stars that we've seen
before we see from another another view
and we also see several stars through
the horizon here but the main thrust in
the plasma physics areas is on the
energetic interactions what happens when
these energetic streams of particles
come into our atmosphere and create
these beautiful sights beautiful and
very powerful sights this also takes a
lot of teamwork it takes many people not
just the seven or eight people that are
in orbit but many people on the ground
to put the vehicle together to help make
decisions to watch over all the things
that are happening so we have a very
large ground contingent of people
there's an incredible amount of teamwork
that goes into one of these particular
missions and as we all know you have to
rely on an awful lot of people to help
you I'd like to change now a little bit
from doing science experiments in space
to looking ahead and looking at what
some human capabilities in space are for
several minutes we've seen pictures of
astronomy telescopes being deployed from
satellites this is the long-duration
exposure facility which has been
deployed from the shuttle it is out
there as a satellite now looking at the
long-duration effects of space
environment cosmic rays on a variety of
materials we've also come a long way
from the Buck Rogers in the Flash Gordon
that I knew in my books and comic books
and TV movies
this was Buck Rogers this
Phantasy only 25 years ago now it's real
it's a reality people go out there
routinely and fly around as a an
individual satellite in their manned
maneuvering unit flying in space at
18,000 miles an hour very accurately
keeping time with a space shuttle and we
can now do a variety of things with
these people out there in extra
vehicular activity we've been able to
bring in satellites into the orbiter and
repair them take them from being a dare
elected space and rejuvenating them this
particular solar maximum satellite was
fixed with the addition of a new power
supply and new science experiments one
of our explorers is here in the middle
taking a quick trip down the payload Bay
with the manned maneuvering unit in the
meantime we've gotten into construction
in space just a little over a year ago
about a year ago some MIT experiments
called the easy experiments were put up
on the orbiter in order to look at the
ability of space-suited astronauts to go
out there and construct things in space
to actually build structures the object
here first was to verify that the
training that was accomplished in
underwater tanks first done here at MIT
and then at the Marshall Space Flight
Center were indeed accurate in
predicting the amount of time and energy
and workloads that are needed by people
to do construction activities in space
NASA in its space station which I'm
going to turn to in a minute is not sure
yet how they're going to construct it
will they send people out and build
beams like this or will they use
automated boxes like this access can to
build the structures and here you see
access putting out a reasonably large
trust structure about 30 meters long
almost 100 feet out of the cargo bay the
orbiter to take a look at very large
structures whether they can be done by
humans or automated the results although
not final show that the humans did a
very nice job and also that the
automated system could work quite
properly well why are we doing those
things why are we going out there to
build trust structures well we're going
out there so that we can create a
permanent presence in space this is
President Reagan's buzzword that
everybody uses it's called a space
station to give you an idea of the scale
it's 500 feet approximately from tip to
tip from solar panels
or panel almost 400 feet high from
bottom if I can use that word to the top
the orbiter is about a hundred and 25
feet long you can get an idea of the
size of the scale of the activities
going on or that will be going on
onboard the space station and we need to
have the data to understand how to put
this up and how to use it as I said a
minute ago the space station is going to
bring an entirely new capability to the
United States we are for the first time
in a long time going to be out be able
to keep people up in space for long
durations we have to go back and take a
look at the biomedical research that
we've done in the past to make sure that
we can keep people up there safely and
happily the current plan is to have
people in orbit for about three months
at a time
that's the duration of the experiments
that we've had on Skylab back in the
early 70s again we found no irreversible
changes the Soviets in contrast have had
people up for as long as eight months
and although the data there is somewhat
weak they indicate that they have not
seen any reversible or irreversible
changes also although a lot of strange
things happen they find they have to
bring their people back into a hospital
for a month or a month and a half to
recuperate they have to bring them out
of their vehicle horizontally on
stretchers and very gradually expose
them again to the full upright stance
here on earth that may not be a problem
coming back on a space shuttle from a
space station but if we follow the
National Commission on space and some of
our earlier speakers and end up going to
Mars or having permanent colonies in
space who's going to put that first
hospital in Mars up so we really need to
understand what's going on and these are
some of the things that are that are
happening to give you an idea of the
manned or the human presence in in orbit
we'll have a series of beginning four
modules each one of these four modules
is about twice as big twice as long as a
Space Lab module if you look closely you
can see the logo of the European Space
Agency and also of the Rising Sun of
Japan it will be an international
collaborative partnership effort with
many different countries and people
around the world so we're learning to
continue our collaboration or to work
together starting from the Space Lab
series with the european space agency
we're going to have an entirely
new group of people on board we're going
to need engineers and we're going to
need plant growth people and biochemist
and at some point we're going to need
plumbers and electricians and we're
going to need gardeners and we're going
to need poets and artists and every type
of society that we have here on earth
will be into space eventually and the
space station is just one of our
beginnings of it another idea for an
artist conception of what a laboratory
might look like to give you an idea the
scale of things and what's happening
we're going to be able to conduct
long-term experiments in many areas of
material sciences of long duration plant
growth and human and animal physiology
I'd like to turn now to the last part of
my talk which is a little bit
differently oriented at it's part of
Earth observations it's part of what
people feel like when they go into space
and people tell you about the vibration
on launch or the the initial sense of
fullness of the head or some of the
physiological symptoms or tell you in
terms that I don't have the right words
to put in a mental image in your mind
but words of euphoria are floating
fantastic views spectacular the most
amazing views out of sight you can use
all the superlatives you ever want and I
still don't feel that I can convey the
beauty of the Earth from space I think
Ron has done it much better than I could
so I will leave it there I have a series
of space views that I'd like to show you
this is a lake in Canada called Monica
wagon it is very big it was caused by a
meteorite impact a long time ago solid
granite rock the dimensions here are
some 100 kilometers 60 miles in diameter
Lake so you imagine the amount of energy
that was released when that meteorite
collided with the earth and formed that
beautiful Lake moving off to the east
coast of Africa if anybody is interested
in meteorology or climatology or weather
you probably don't get turned on by
clouds because you see them every
evening on the television that's got it
intended I guess sitting home watching
TV the one thing that you don't get from
those satellite views of space and
looking at the clouds and watching them
bring rain or snow to your particular
area you don't see the three-dimensional
aspects you don't see the depth
and you won't see it on this slide
either but you'll have to trust me that
it's there as you look down from space
you can actually see the height of the
clouds you can see them attempt to
billow up and touch the sky very
beautiful very striking very large-scale
moving around now to the Mideast we see
very nicely nature and people living
together the bottom is the Red Sea going
up through the Suez Canal to the
Mediterranean Sea the wonderfully
fertile region of the Nile River Delta
here we see some very interesting round
green dots which turn out to be very
large irrigation fields with a single
arm spray bars where the Egyptians are
reclaiming parts of the desert over
there to make it habitable for people
very large areas being reclaimed moving
around to the Indian Ocean now a very
small probably uninhabited island owned
by France called ill glorious very
beautiful the colors here don't do
justice to what it's really like with
your naked eye the blues and the greens
and the whites of the clouds and the
yellows and the golds and the pinks and
the purples of the deserts it's just
spectacular it's just too too beautiful
to almost be able to describe some other
very interesting geological features
this one in New Zealand it's called
Mount Egmont it is a very lovely
volcanic Mountain with a snow cone on
top it was summer there one of the
things that we noticed very clearly is
this big dark circle around there and
wondered what that was and to give you
an idea how the New England people like
their mountain also they took a look at
it and put a compass on the map through
a circle around it put a fence up and
called this all their national parkland
so all the Sheep grazers are out here on
the outside keeping the grass down so
get a good idea of land use here just
from the color change over New Zealand
moving on to Russia now this is the
Kamchatka Peninsula it's a very active
volcanic region as you all are aware
when you circle the earth at reasonably
low altitudes it takes about an hour and
a half to go around well that very
nicely goes into 24 hours so you get 16
orbits a day and so every 24 hours you
come over approximately the same spot on
earth you move slightly but not too much
and every day that we'd come over this
Peninsula
we would see another volcano that was
active there are more than a half a
dozen volcanoes in here active ones you
see one right here and there a bunch of
them coming through the splendor of the
earth is really tremendous
remember this is Russia notice that it's
not in red a lot of people still take a
look at the maps and say well what are
the borders look like and the one thing
you realize is that you don't see
borders here this extremely beautiful
place sometimes you're lucky and you get
to see Los Angeles here's one of those
days when the clouds have been blown out
to sea you actually see the city of Los
Angeles down near Catalina island's we
have San Diego to orient you and I would
like to point out some of the things
that you do see you can see runways Los
Angeles International Airport you can
see a general gray you don't see
individual buildings but a general gray
area you can see some road structures
very nice grid structures up here and to
parts of Los Angeles so that you know
that there are people down there
even from our vantage point in space to
sort of end the lecture and end on note
that I know or believe that that Ron
would agree with me on and that is that
the Earth from space is is truly truly
miraculous as I said you don't see the
borders in the countries you don't see
the different cultures you don't see all
of our differences down here what you do
is you see one earth takes an hour and a
half to go around it's very small in
terms of time and as you look up there
and look down on it and be able to drink
in the color of the earth you realize
that we all share a responsibility to
take care of it so with that I'd like to
conclude and thank you
thank you very much Myron I think it was
a perfect counterpoint like to end the
symposium here by thanking those
speakers who contributed so much to them
heating today as well as the other
members of the planning committee that
contributed to putting this symposium
together
[Applause]